[MUSIC PLAYING]
Crypto, cryptocurrency?
Yeah.
No, I don't use crypto.
I may have made $1 here
or there off of crypto.
I'm actually not
really a big fan.
And maybe I'm a
little embarrassed
that I've invested in it,
because I think it's wasteful.
I think it's using a
lot of Earth's resources
to do something
unnecessary and silly.
And so I'm actually,
yeah, pretty anti-crypto,
although, I have a personally
benefited from it financially.
You know, I constantly
have FOMO about this,
and so much so that we
like parked $400 into it.
And it's like halved
since I parked it.
So you know, um, my opinion on
crypto was kind of a little bit
negative these days.
I mean, I think that the shoe's
going to drop at some point,
that it's going to experience
a massive deflation.
I think it has a
great vision, and I
think it's kind of going towards
a really important problem.
But I think where we're sort
of at with it right now,
there's also a lot of
hype, and a lot of yeah,
people who maybe don't
understand it yet.
And things that are
sort of just being
done for the sake of
being attached to crypto,
and not necessarily
of actually getting
at the heart of
the real problem.
So I would say I
have mixed feelings.
And I do not currently sort of
use it on a day-to-day basis.
I would say it's
a waste of time.
And if you really
want blockchain, just
Git and GitHub.
That's really going
to get me murdered.
I am glad that a
lot of my friends
have made a lot of money.
That is my opinion.
I would not bet on being
able to do the same thing.
It has potential.
And I have friends who are
really interested and invested
in this topic.
So I just bought a
little bit of crypto.
I don't really play with it.
I just bought it.
I just I don't touch it.
So I'm like, OK, like if
this gets even more pumped
in the future, then
at least I have
some sort of savings already.
There's a lot of hype
bro energy in that space.
And I think that some of
it's fun, and some of it's
not my favorite.
I don't personally have
any cryptocurrency.
I have a lot of questions
around Web3, and all of that.
But I feel ambivalent.
Yeah, I feel ambivalent.
[MUSIC PLAYING]